i've announced five new measures
we're protecting jobs through the new
jobs
support scheme the government will
directly support
the wages of people in work giving
businesses who face depressed demand
through the difficult winter months the
option of keeping employees
in a job on shorter hours rather
than making them redundant we're also
extending the self-employed scheme
to sit alongside that and i've announced
a range of measures
to ease cash flow concerns for
businesses
allowing them to focus on protecting
jobs
pay as you grow will ease the repayment
terms
for bounce-back loans we're giving
people more time to pay back their
deferred taxes
and i'm cancelling the planned increase
in vat
for hospitality and tourism through to
the end
of march i know people are anxious and
afraid right now
but i want them to know that we have a
plan to protect jobs
and support businesses and what was true
at the beginning of this crisis
remains true it's on all of us
to get through this together
let's take a look at those measures
first announced in the commons this
afternoon
the jobs support scheme will begin in
november and run for six
months employees in smaller or
struggling businesses who are working
reduced hours will get a third of their
lost salary topped up by the government
the self-employment income support
scheme has also been extended
and there's a pay-as-you-grow extension
to the bounce-back loan scheme to give
businesses
up to 10 years to repay debts for the
hospitality and tourism sectors
the va t cut to 5 has been extended
until spring in a moment we'll be
hearing from kate mccann
in westminster first to our business
presenter ian king who's in the city
for us uh ian a big moment for the
chancellor today furlough coming to an
end
a new package to get us through the
winter what does it look like
well it's considerably less generous uh
than the existing furlough scheme is the
most obvious point to make sarah at the
moment uh
an employee is entitled to 80
of their wages for doing nothing now
they'll have to be working at least a
third of their hours and if they do so
they'll be guaranteed
probably according to the treasury some
77
of their wages now it's particularly
unfavorable to employers interestingly
enough because at the moment
uh the employer is making a
substantially lower contribution
to uh their employees salary some 20
well this rises to 55 under the new
scheme
which is worth pointing out it's
actually much much less generous
than the scheme in germany on which uh
mr sunak's new scheme has been based the
german scheme of course credited
with avoiding uh big job losses in the r
and the aftermath of the financial
crisis
a decade ago it's an idea that's been uh
picked up and uh run with by rishi sunak
but as i say
the uh government support scheme that's
been unveiled today is substantially
less generous
than uh the uh scheme in germany on
which it was based i find that very
interesting
and there are certainly concerns which
the chancellor did nothing
to try and run away from in his press
conference a moment ago that this is
still going to lead to a big rise
in unemployment now the chancellor
didn't say how big the rise in
unemployment would be
on the back of this he merely referred
people to the bank of england's forecast
which is around seven and a half percent
uh joblessness and the opi the office of
budget responsibility well under their
most stops in the optimistic scenario
unemployment rises to 9.7 so either way
you're probably
looking at a big rise in unemployment
it's difficult to say precisely how much
but looking at some of the uh forecasts
that
are starting to drop into my inbox from
uh economists around the city
we're looking at uh for example uh simon
french over at pamela gordon
he says that he was modeling a rise of
one and a half million
in the uh unemployment total between now
and the end of the year he says this
will probably bring that down by between
a quarter
and a third but either way you're still
looking at probably an increase
in unemployment of over a million well
that's undoubtedly the biggest measure
other measures include an extension of
the vat
temporary cut in vat for hospitality
businesses that will last until
the end of the financial year now there
are deferrals for other self-employed in
terms of
when they have to pay their
self-assessment tax bills and they've
been
extension to the various government loan
schemes which have already paid out
something like 58 billion pounds
in support to businesses up and down the
country that money of course
has to be repaid sometime and there's
been a lot of anxiety
among banks here in the city that
they're ever going to see that money
back because the
government guarantees only last so long
so those were the main measures there
was nothing
on business rates relief which is
something that i think will be of great
concern
to uh the retail sector in particular
but worth pointing out that big
set-piece moment sarah right at the
opening
when uh mr sunak was unveiling his uh
his speech
he was flanked by francis o'grady of the
tuc and by dane carolyn fairburne from
the cbi
very unusual to see those two in public
and uh
variously hinting that uh they were
supportive of this measure i mean
it was a quite an astute political move
to get both the tuc
and the cbi on side i feel for this and
accordingly
it's why you're uh you're seeing uh some
there you go you can see the pictures
now
then carolyn ferben there on the right
of the screen francis o'grady from the
tc on the left-hand side
of the screen as i say very very
interesting that they were involved in
the
presentation of that speech to get the
employers
and the unions on side is no small
matter
and it's very striking that not only has
the cbi been very favorable
of this but so the federation of small
businesses and the british
chambers of commerce because of course
it's their members ultimately who are
going to be making these
very very difficult decisions about uh
whether they make people unemployed or
not